[Music]
foreign
there is one Catalyst that can amplify
your organization's creativity and
ignite its impact today we will talk
about the importance and value of
diversity in our social networks I'm
Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
[Music]
today I am super excited to be joined by
Adina Sterling who is an associate
professor of organizational behavior at
Stanford GSB Adena studies the causes
and consequences of Human Relationships
and organizations and markets and she
teaches a popular elective class called
Equity by Design and runs a lab by the
same name welcome a Dean I'm super
excited to get a chance to talk with you
thanks Matt it's great to be here yes
well thanks for being here so let's go
ahead and get started a lot of your work
focuses on social networks for many of
us social networks refer to applications
like Facebook or Twitter and Linkedin
what do you mean by social networks and
what types of insights can you learn
from them right so that's a great
question to begin with and you're
absolutely right we hear social networks
when we think about Facebook and
Linkedin and Instagram and things that
12 and 13 year olds are more Savvy at us
than we are so what they are are the
patterns of interactions and
communication that happens between
various entities so social scientists
will study social networks that occur
between individuals between groups
between teams between societies
organizations institutions and so social
networks is a construct that travels
different levels and levels of analyzes
and we care about them because a lot of
the outcomes that individuals groups and
organizations experience have to do with
the social networks that they have where
they are within this pattern of
relationships and so
oftentimes we get a lot of our social
resources from social networks and so
they can be awfully important I see so a
social network is essentially a way of
mapping the different connections and
relationships we have within groupings
of people that's right as you know Adina
this podcast focuses a lot on
communication so I'm wondering what role
does community play Within social
networks and have you been able to
determine any best practices that
organizations use to maximize the impact
of communication within their networks
so communication and the social networks
are foundational to why
social networks exist so if I can't
communicate effectively to you or you to
me our social tie goes away
so a lot of the way that we understand
social ties is the transfer of
information
advice care social support and of course
being able to communicate those aspects
of Life effectively the kind of care
that somebody would Express to another
depends on their ability to communicate
that in a way that's empathetic and real
and so communication is foundational
just to social networks what can
organizations do to help employees
communicate and help employees
communicate with clients and other
stakeholders I always hear Matt go back
to the importance of culture so if the
organization can put into place the
right Norms the right expectations the
right language so that people can
communicate and they sort of know where
the boundaries are and what you know
where where not to cross boundaries
those can be really helpful ways of
helping employees communicate they're
once in needs their ideas to one another
and to other stakeholders wow so I just
learned that I I've been a social
networking researcher for all these
years and I didn't know that that's what
I was no that's great so uh thank you
for for sharing that the communication
is absolutely critical uh in
understanding social networks and it
sounds like organizations that put a
priority on helping people communicate
the value of communication and and
allowing people to feel that notion
we've talked about before on this
podcast of psychological safety to feel
comfortable communicating that's right
it can be much more effective do you
mind if I add one oh please yes to what
organizations can do and what you just
teed up made me think of this
another important part of communication
that organizations can tap into is the
notion that it can be multifaceted
so verbal communication of course is one
way of communicating auditory
communication but it's not the only way
and so especially organizations that
recognize
neurodiversity for example will do
things in a team setting like take
pauses give people think time allow
people to write down ideas in the middle
of a meeting so that People's Natural
strengths because we all have different
strengths don't all dominate so that you
know only certain people don't get to
communicate their ideas organizations
that do this well
collect ideas from many different people
and allow for communication to come
through many different mediums
I love that idea and it brings us really
nicely into my next set of questions
around what you teach in your Equity by
design class and in the the lab that you
run so it's really important from what
I'm hearing you say that organizations
don't just lock into one way of
communicating that they'd be very open
to multiple ways and they put a priority
on communication I will often recommend
that organizations take time to reflect
on their communication at the end of
meetings or one-on-one interaction spend
a few minutes just talking about the
quality of the communication not
rehashing what was said necessarily and
also as part of performance reviews and
other big meetings talk about
communication and what you add so nicely
to it is it's not just one monolithic
thing there are lots of different ways
to communicate and we want to make sure
that everybody can bring their best
selves to the communication can you
share with us some of the concepts you
teach in your Equity by design class as
well as the topics you study in your
Equity by Design Lab what role does
communication play in these efforts
sure so my class as you mentioned is on
diversity equity and inclusion and those
are really three different ideas in
thinking about the importance of
communication it is awfully important
for diversity so let me say a little
more please we've now had several
decades of of work done by social
scientists on what diversity buys you
what is the diversity bonus has been the
question and when people from different
backgrounds that have different ideas
come together what research has shown is
that they tend to outperform from a
creativity and Innovation standpoint
groups that are more homogeneous but the
key to having those benefits come about
is the ability for people to be able to
communicate so you could have a really
diverse group right and if everybody
shuts down and nobody's communicating it
becomes really hard to build off of each
other's ideas to have those creative
breakthroughs you need people to be
willing to share their thoughts and
their ideas and so that's that's one way
communication is is really key the
importance of diversity equity and
inclusion are are critical for many
aspects of an organization for sure and
I'm curious to hear even more
but in terms of communication they drive
creativity and Innovation and it seems
to me that it's so important for
organizations to recognize that and
celebrate it and to encourage it have
you seen best practices or do you teach
best practices to really help leaders
amplify the diversity that they have so
they can get those results that they're
looking for
yeah so for my classmate I have what I
call a better practices Playbook so oh I
love it so well first before you go why
better practices and not best practice
okay so that is a good question the
reason is that when it comes to the
what I found is that sometimes the the
great can be the enemy of the good and
so when I first began teaching this
topic at Stanford I had people say to me
oh my gosh one of the things I like
about your class is that we're taught to
incrementally just get going right it
doesn't we don't have to have the
perfect plan for diversity equity and
inclusion what we can do is is begin and
have better practices from where we're
at so anyway it's just it's the idea of
that the great shouldn't be the enemy of
the good I love it I'm calling them
better practice better practices what
are some from your class yeah so one
important one is to understand that
because diversity has benefits sometimes
you need to do things differently as a
leader the thing that diversity really
helps you with is sometimes slowing down
to take the time to be creative to make
better choices and have better Solutions
so there was this terrific study done
that was actually looking at juries and
they found these researchers that juries
that were more diverse they were more
deliberate people came more prepared and
better able to argue their ideas and
outcomes generally reviewed as being
better when there are these more diverse
groups and so and so the first really
it's about buying in and understanding
that it might take a little bit longer
to build a diverse team but that has
some benefits in the long run so taking
the time and being thoughtful about
putting the team together and then
giving the team space to actually
Leverage The diverse perspectives that
they bring can be really helpful that's
right that's right a lot of businesses
so much about rushing and being first
and fast and it sounds like what I'm
hearing you say is sometimes being more
deliberate and slowing down can give you
an advantage as well yes great yeah and
then also building up the right culture
around the team who becomes key right so
that helping people feel connected and
safe and that their voice has value
exactly yeah great many of those
listening uh into our podcast today work
for organizations that are in various
stages of implementing their Deni
programs based on your experience what
are some of the best ways to implement
assess and reinforce these programs sure
so I like to say if you can get buy-in
from the top uh oftentimes there are
Grassroots its efforts within
organizations that are terrific around
Dei and Leadership can feel as though
they're responding to Dei efforts and
and that's fine but if there can be
leadership from the top and a
collaboration with employees on what
their Dei needs are and B needs are that
can be a really effective way to go
about things
um the other concept I would I would
just add here is that I do like to talk
about within organization's
what they think of as education so we
all think about Innovation and kind of
being at the bleeding edge the analogy
doesn't quite work the same way but
traditionally there are more
marginalized groups within organizations
and so sometimes sitting with and taking
the temperature of those groups and
figuring out how to implement policy
changes that are effective there can
have enormous spillover effects for
everyone so for example if an
organization goes on and surveys all
recent parents for mothers fathers and
the like about time off policies they'll
hear a lot of things in there that could
also help older individuals that are
taking care of their parents
um individuals that have family that are
further away and so organizations that
sit and listen to more marginalized
groups oftentimes can use those insights
and blow them out and have effective
policies for multiple groups within
organizations that's really really
fantastic it's it starts with listening
and then collaboration and it has to
come not just from the Grassroots but
also from the top and and that's what
leads to success more and more as I do
these podcasts the the role of listening
and taking the time to to hear what
others are saying is really a key
ingredient to success in many aspects
and it sounds like d e and I is no
different
I wanted to address another area of your
research that I found really fascinating
you've identified something you term the
confidence Gap as a potential
contributor to gender differences we see
in the workplace such as equity and pay
can you explain what the confidence Gap
is and how can it be addressed
sure so I'm glad we're chatting about
this because sometimes
the confidence Gap can be misunderstood
so I'll first explain it and then talk
about where it comes from because that's
a real key to this so the confidence Gap
that idea came from a study that I and
some researchers here at Stanford did
where we tracked the
outcomes of college students in
engineering programs at 27 institutions
and it was a longitudinal studies we
were interested in people's what we
called self-efficacy how much confidence
they had in their ability to do
engineering and stem and Mathematics
type problems
early on how that changed over time
where they were with respect to
self-efficacy as they were entering the
workplace and then what happened after
they entered and what we found is that
women and men did differ in the level of
self-efficacy they they felt or they
reported okay so this is a
self-perceived measure if you will of
your own confidence in in your ability
to solve engineering problems so on and
so forth so we found we did find a
gender gap we found that men had higher
levels of confidence than women we found
that this effect held within
specific kinds of engineering programs
and so Engineers I was an engineer as an
undergraduate in at Ohio State so I but
the chemical engine there's a lot of
engineering snobbery so sometimes it's
like oh well the aerospace engineers are
the smart and the electrical or the
smart and the chemical or this so anyway
we wanted to look with in engineering
major and we still found this effect so
it wasn't that women were only going
into some engineering fields and then
others and that was leading to this
difference and the confidence Gap it
remained within engineering major it
also remained with we looked within GPA
so when we looked at only those with
sort of a 3.9 GPA or above which believe
it or not they the number of students in
our study had that had that GPA it
remained there it remained within every
GPA category and so one of the things we
then did Matt was say okay does this
help explain the gender wage Gap and we
found that it did we did a mediation
analysis on the first salaries that
people received and and it did it turned
out that once we accounted for
for the level of self-confidence people
had most of that gender gap could be
explained away now the thing I want to
emphasize though is that this Gap
doesn't come from either of the sky
right it comes from our society that
provides expectations and Norms about
who can be an engineer who should be
confident in their ability to be an
engineer so I want to be really careful
that this is not about blaming either
women that are less confident this is
coming from a society that conditioned
women in different ways from men to be
either confident in their abilities and
so so one of the things that sometimes
I'll get asked is okay what can we do
about this I'm really quick to say okay
this is not a fix the women right you
know great thing there's lots of things
that we can do especially within stem
where our study focused we know that
when you diversify the faculty and you
have more female faculty that can be an
important signal that can have important
signaling value for women and increase
their confidence you can structure teams
in ways that there are more there's
greater gender balance and so something
that can happen in engineering and this
doesn't necessarily reflect my
experience but some research and also
anecdotes I'll share that that in in
engineering programs you'll have
five-person teams
sometimes one woman and then that one
woman is the Note Taker so there's all
sorts of small
um daily kinds of interactions and ways
of communicating
within groups that can lead people to
have different levels of confidence in
their abilities and we just need to
figure out ways to stop all of this
there's been an underlying theme in our
conversation today Adina around the
impact of the culture and the Norms
within organizations or in the case of
what we just discussed society and and
to what I'm taking away and I'd love for
you to verify this is is that to make
the kind of change that you're talking
about we've talked about in other
episodes here it's really about
looking at the larger factors that are
influencing the communication or
behavior and and that's where you have
to to adjust and adapt and focus to have
the kind of impact that we're talking
about
and while that can feel daunting I think
you've got some evidence and and I know
in what you teach some better practices
for how to go about doing that so so
thank you
before we end I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everyone who
joins me does that sound all right that
sounds great all right if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you have ever received as a five to
seven word presentation slide title what
would it be
what a question
what came to mind for me is paint a
picture tell a story oh I love it paint
a picture tell a story so we've talked a
lot about storytelling here but but give
me some more detail about painting a
picture sure so when people are hearing
your story that you're communicating
if if they can put themselves in your
shoes or your sets of experiences
that's the picture I'm talking about and
I do think so much of Dei comes from
perspective taking and empathy for those
that might be different from us and so
that ability to say
here's how I felt in this moment and why
that can be a I think an effective way
of communicating this is so true and as
a communicator if you're looking to
paint that picture so people can
understand your perspective it changes
your focus it changes what you're going
to say and how you say it it's going to
be about emotion it's going to be about
detail and that's so critical and I
think when we reflect on the speakers
that move us the most or ones that can
do that well which leads me nicely I
think to our second question which is
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
all right so I I'm going to not directly
answer this question in a way that uh
that this came to me which is I grew up
going to church I grew up going to black
churches and within that tradition there
are wonderful or orders with just really
rich linguistic Styles and and so I
thought about a number of black
politicians today from that tradition so
you know Stacy Abrams Raphael Warnock
Barack Obama I could name others you
could name others it also was a very
rich oral tradition because during
various parts of history when black
people weren't allowed to be able to
read and write what you understood came
from the black church on the Sunday
morning so anyway those those I really
admire
that linguistic style and ways of that
way of communicating yeah well thank you
for sharing and thank you for taking a
very different perspective on that when
I when I think of the orations I've seen
in black churches the the emotion and
the ability to to move those in the pews
is is fantastic and while that style is
very appropriate in that moment many of
the aspects of what makes it effective
apply in other types of communication as
well so I appreciate you highlighting
that
third and final question what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
sure okay so
the first is think about your audience
about your audience's perspective and
I feel privileged to be able to practice
this as a as an instructor as a
professor and
[Music]
for me that was a big shift that I made
in my teaching trajectory when I stopped
trying to teach and I started trying to
communicate those are I thought about
those two things differently and in fact
I think that communication is just King
from that standpoint the second one is
use emotion rather than shy away from it
linen is is fine that can that can be
effective and then less is more this is
my third one
so it does not surprise me at all that
audience is something that that you
would absolutely see is important and
and that distinction between teaching
and communicating I think all people who
are really good instructors have that
moment where they realize it's not just
about relaying information it's about
connecting emotion is critical I think
your other answers have highlighted that
it takes a confidence to be able to come
to that place to go in with I've just
got a couple ideas not all of these
ideas and and I appreciate that
well Adina thank you this has been
you're welcome really really insightful
and a lot of fun and really helpful
thank you for taking the time and and
for making us better and for sharing
your better practices with us you're
welcome Matt it was a lot of fun great
you've been listening to another episode
of think fast talk smart the podcast a
production of Stanford Graduate School
of Business
podcast was produced by Jenny Luna Kevin
Patel and me Matt Abrahams with special
thanks to Podium podcast company
to find more episodes visit our website
at
gsb.stampord.edu or find us wherever you
get your podcasts including YouTube for
more business related content follow the
business school on social media at
Stanford GSB you can also find the
podcast and follow us on LinkedIn and
Instagram